[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie I hope you
guys all had an amazing New Year's but
the holiday is over it's time to go back
to 221 Baker Street episode 1 the empty
hearse just aired so this first video
will be a non-spoilery review just
because a lot of people might not have
seen it yet I'll also be doing a Q&A
video tomorrow for episode 1 so if you
had any specific questions about things
that happened during the episode or
what's going on with the characters now
be sure to write it in the comments and
let me know that you want me to include
that in the video I'll also be doing a
detailed breakdown in the episode either
tomorrow or Friday - so many amazing
moments where to start here my top 5
number 5 Sherlock and Mycroft throughout
the episode Sherlock and Mycroft have a
number of scenes that really turned the
dial on mock resentment and anger all
the way up to 11 you also get this sense
that if Sherlock were ever to be
incapacitated for any reason Mycroft
could totally step in and be a Sherlock
proxy I'm really interested to see if
the series continues to play with that
idea it's so much fun to watch Sherlock
and Mycroft dance around each other but
my Crofts abilities as a detective
actually come to the forefront and I
thought that was a really interesting
way that the character got explored that
we didn't see in series 1 or 2 number
for all of your fan theories are
addressed all of the Sherlock Holmes
theories were filmed and presented in
the most hilarious possible way or at
least the most plausible Sherlock lives
theories Mark Gatiss and Steven Moffat
essentially wheat from behind the camera
every time we saw a new theory play out
on screen and it was glorious I don't
think that they'll ever explicitly state
which scenario was the correct one just
meaning that there's elements of truth
in every single scenario that we saw on
screen in case you didn't see it I
actually did my own Sherlock Lewis video
but my favorite one during the episode
was actually the Sherlock fan club
theory I don't want to spoil it here but
it was hilarious I mean it was a total
WTF moment number three the mine palace
I really liked the way they turned it
into a joke in this episode to be clear
he does use it several times but I'm
talking about the joke that was made
near the end of the episode they also
updated a lot of the way they showed the
mine palace visually and how it plays
out on screen I kind of thought it was
unnecessary for them to go into such
great detail of you know what's going on
in Sherlock's mind but I do understand
why they did it that way just because
they want to show new viewers just how
hyperkinetic his mind is number two the
new characters we finally get to meet
Mary Morstan and I love the way they
kind of teased her throughout the
episode
you finally get to see her face in
full-frame I almost liked watching
Sherlock scan her more than I liked him
trying to scan Irene Adler during
scandal Mary isn't a big part of this
episode but because of the wedding she's
a much bigger part of episode 2 so we'll
get to know her a little bit better
during that the other new character is
obviously the villain Charles Augustus
Magnussen I like the way the episode
teased him just like it teased Moriarty
at the end of study in pink but I didn't
think that we should have seen him so
soon just a minor complaint but I did
like how we didn't really see Moriarty
until a great game I think the only
reason why they showed us the face of
the villain in this episode is just
because they want to speed the narrative
up remember during series 2 there was
almost like a whole episode where they
didn't use Moriarty and my number 1
moment the Sherlock and Watson reunion
so it's no surprise that my favorite
moment is watching Sherlock and Watson
get back together it had been implied
for a long time that by the end of this
episode all of the core relationships
would be restored but the real fun part
was just watching the John Locke reunion
play out over the course of the episode
all I could think when Sherlock first
revealed himself to Watson was that
scene during scandal where Watson is
just punching and throttling Sherlock on
the ground during the episode it was
like Sherlock was looking at Watson just
staring death right in the face and just
not seeing it I crept to the edge of my
seat and sure enough the music swells up
and Watson leaps at him as the camera
goes into slow motion it was so
beautiful and hilarious at the same time
there were so many amazing moments in
the episode we could spend all day
talking about them but because I don't
spoil things too much I'll just leave a
lot of those for my breakdown video
tomorrow let me know what your favorite
moment was in the comments below whether
it was the John Locke reunion or it was
just watching all the fan theories kind
of play out on screen here's my actual
review though I thought the episode was
perfection with a few minor exceptions
just like study in pink the real task of
this episode was to form or you know
reform team Sherlock and it did that
perfectly I was amazed at the links that
Stephen Moffat and Mark Gatiss went to
to address all of the fans questions
they quite literally filmed almost every
major Sherlock Liv's theory and then
made fun of themselves in the most
hilarious ways one of the things that
makes Sherlock so great is the wordplay
and Walt Benedict Cumberbatch and Martin
Freeman and the other actors are largely
responsible for the on-screen
interpretation of those jokes it's
really Mark Gatiss who deserves the
credit he was the only credited writer
on the episode
so he definitely deserves the first
highfive but after that it's all comer
batch and Freeman not to leave out the
rest of the cast though Amanda Abbington
is a very welcome addition to Team
Sherlock but needless to say she will be
a very formidable opponent to Sherlock
over Watson's affections the sheer
amount of fanservice that the episode
performed was amazing and I love that
they were able to do that for us without
seeming too ridiculous one of the things
I've always liked about the show is how
playful it allows everyone to be without
the actors having to step out of
character so big reminder Q&A tomorrow
be sure to write all your questions
about the episode in the comments below
episode 2 is on Sunday and it'll be the
same drill I'll do a non-spoilery review
right up to the episode airs and then on
Monday I'll do a Q&A video and a
breakdown to that episode and it'll be
the same thing that next week right now
you can click here to watch my Sherlock
list video you can decide how right you
think I was based on all the theories
that they presented during the episode
but I feel like I was pretty close and
you can click here to watch my New
Year's video thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you